toy thank you so much again for your
insight we'll see you again after this
round before the final round
absolutely thanks for joining us okay
and here we go these two in place eight
and nine on the table what's happening
the game has started and the three of us
here are very happy in the studio
because it's the english opening yay
one of simon's favorite openings as well
uh meanwhile abdu's a tour of using an
opening line a variation that brought
him success in the world rapid
championship we've seen some early
trades actually white temporarily
sacrificed tonight but won it back so
it's level material right now but it is
a crazy position white's queen has come
out early
black's bishop is giving a pin to the
white knight trying to break through to
the white king and
yeah it's wild it's uh really really
sharp already both players wanting to go
for that win is that yeah it's that's
something you play in sort of the
must-win situation yes especially what
level neronian has done normally black
plays a more solid variation here it's a
risky one now for black
because white's queen is out white has a
central pawn but
yeah it's clear that levon wants to get
that one he needs to win actually to
overtake his young rival now in terms of
points wow simon what do you think i
mean you know a lot about the english
opening i do yeah i mean i well normally
i mean i did a chessboard course um
which was a little bit different to this
it was recommending you go for
fianchetto on the king side the iron
english obviously one of the best chords
you can ever get if you're interested
but um i this just seems very
complicated i'm trying to work it out
black's weakened his king by pushing
that pawn near his king
white's got the two bishops uh it's
really hard to assess but if you need to
win the game you go for risks you go for
unbalance in the position which is what
we have here so very exciting uh
position yeah normally with such crazy
imbalances here it's the pawn structure
again uh it does favor the more
experienced player or the player who
handles strategic uh stuff just as well
as the tactical possibilities that will
arise and actually this is basically a
mirror image of what levon auronian did
to magnus carlsen in the last game in
terms of the pawn structure white now
has these two doubled isolated pawns on
the c file and that's exactly what level
did to magnus in the previous game and
he's done it again he's given his
opponent these weak pawns ivanka i see
you smiling i'm i'm smiling just for one
reason because there's only one game in
my database and it comes from 1934.
and that was between
tatakova and george allen thomas so
what are the chances that uh someone
picked up the history books and went
yeah you know i'll copy that
yeah what are the chances do you think
that's the or is it coincidence i would
be amazed if the players could name that
game but maybe we can ask them later who
knows abdusatorov has been playing this
exact opening with white for the last
few months it's been his main weapon and
level neroni and if you look at the
clock times he's game time he's up to 16
minutes he has prepared this for sure so
maybe he's seen that one ivanka
maybe maybe it's not often that uh
the most current game is from 1934.
i like it
yeah i do remember though in the 2007 i
think at the um european individual
championships that you were telling us
that you prepared
using some game from i don't know i'm
going to say 1800 or 1900 or some kings
gambit really fashionable theory though
i kind of like this romantic era where
um these ideas these players you know
loved attacking love giving up
material unfortunately nowadays
you know with computers you can't play
as romantic chess but i think there's a
lot to be said and you see some of the
top players doing this like duboff he
does this regularly where he he tries to
find forgotten ideas and brings them
back to life um ideas
maybe were played a number of years ago
at least and not played that often and
rather than following the fashion i
think this is what more players should
do they should try to find peculiar
peculiar options and go against the
grain a bit more it also leads to more
exciting uh chess um it kind of
resembling a dutch now on the board a
little bit uh david as well with his
with his black last move trying to bring
the bishop out um lev trying to get all
his pieces uh nicely developed and he's
got the same pawn structure as he had in
the last game remember lev was playing
against magnus's sea pawns and he had a
very nice position and it's the same
pawn structure here and it's very
important to to learn about structures
um not just openings but what to do
against certain structures and here he's
stopping that c pawn from moving he's
going to try to win a c pawn so uh so
yeah i mean maybe this is uh you know if
if white doesn't do something quickly
it's going to end up being quite good
for uh black here phil yeah and he did
the exact same thing against magnus
right not just the pawns but he also
pushed this one forward later brought
his bishop to the side uh to try and
target white's pawns and we should also
mention there was a trick in the last
position black looked like he could have
gone a pawn up capturing in the center
of the board but this would have walked
into a pin here so white would have
simply stepped the pawn forward hitting
the black knight which cannot move
because the queen would have fallen
behind it so levon avoiding that trap
dodging that one and instead just
pushing upon bringing his bishop out to
the side and
we have talked about the bishop power as
well but white's bishops right now are
not that impressive um especially this
guy struggling to get into the game so
i'm wondering whether maybe abductor
would think about pushing this pawn
forward to try and at least activate his
bishop along this diagonal i i would
love to place a bet here so ivanka
mentioned that game um between tartakova
and the famous george thomas and they
actually are quite famous players but it
was 1934. i reckon lev knows that game
if we get a chance to ask him i reckon
he knows that game it's like one of
those people who's got this great chess
history i can see your vank is shaking
ahead there this sounds like a bet we
have so i wonder what people at home
think but i reckon lev is aware of that
game i'm making notes so remember to ask
lavon about if he if he's aware that
this game is uh
identical to a game from 1934 i have a
suspicion that uh levon is freestyling
and it just happens to be the choice of
george thomas from 1934. uh well they're
still following the game
i think he's a secret thomas fan i think
it's clear he's uh you know but what do
you reckon david i'm more on simon's
side here the just
just the fact that love is playing so
quickly also it's such a rare line this
actually i've i remember seeing several
uh magazine articles and book articles
about this line and it's not recommended
for black
so the fact that levon aronian has
picked it up must mean he studied it in
detail also remember he played
abdusatorov in the world rapid
championship a couple of months ago just
over christmas new year he lost abdusa
off in this opening a slightly different
branch of this opening so he knew the
soaping was coming he must have looked
for a different way to approach it with
black and it's very hard to just
freestyle and come up with an opening
off the top of your head
it feels like he's studied it before and
top players when they look for new ideas
they often go back in the past they find
what's been played before and then they
modernize it with the help of computers
so
he might not remember the players of
that game he might just remember there
was an example in the past
i'm inclined to agree with simon sorry
ivanka
well it's okay
afterwards we'll find out yeah and uh
here comes the improvement uh
well the in the previous game from 1934
black actually just developed the light
squared bishop here you know levon is
playing in a very confrontational style
and is putting pressure on white central
pawn
okay and i'm just doing a bit of
searching here apparently the top
computer move was this last one so maybe
he does remember that game he's just
checked it with a computer and improved
on it and look at the clock times uh
level running up to 16 minutes he still
gained a minute from when he started the
game and
okay we're used to that from level
neroni and he does trust his instincts
he does play super fast these days but
it does feel like he's still in his
opening preparation or at least he's
familiar with this type of idea
and remember everyone this is the game
between number eight up to the door of
and nine
live on the table
a win here would be a
huge step towards qualifying for the
knockout stage a loss
a huge step towards going home from the
tournament this is a critical game
yeah i think if levon aronian doesn't
win this one he's basically out right
yeah must be yeah because uh ty just by
the numbers said 22
maybe you'll be in maybe not but if
levon loses this one the maximum he can
get 21 he would need a lot of luck on
his side yeah to qualify with 21 points
and he finishes off against andreas
penko
who is currently on 21 points
not easy at all no
okay so this position there is a threat
as well from black maybe we just jump in
one more time just to show black's idea
with his last move the first new move
with that we've seen in this game on
move 15 and uh it's all to do with this
pin so white cannot go and capture this
black pawn because the queen would fall
behind it and with a nasty check so
there's problems on this file white does
have to support his pawn in the middle
but now once black's bishop does land on
this diagonal it has even more scope
and yeah the more i look at this more i
think black is in charge white is the
one fighting for equality in this game
it's all to do with these weak pawns as
well the white bishops are not
impressive black's pieces are great this
knight is on a nice outpost it will at
some point force white to capture it but
if this ever happens black can even
choose to capture either way then yes
both sides have doubled pawns but black
is the one doing well and okay slightly
surprising black develops this bishop
this way but i guess levon wants to put
pressure on this pawn
what do you think guys
i prefer black slightly here yeah i mean
i i've had many bad versions of this
kind of position as black because it is
like a dutch uh but those white sea
pawns uh the double pawns we pointed out
which uh lev targeted in the last game
as well they they they're certainly
something which is is going to be a
problem for white for a long long time
uh the two bishops they're not very good
i prefer the knight i expect white will
actually have to take this night off
capture this night whenever you've got
an option in chess of making a capture
you just ask yourself a very simple
thing is my piece stronger than that
piece and i think here if you have a
look uh the knight is ready to do lots
of vicious things uh white's bishop
pointing at the night is is really not
doing anything and it's just a simple
little thing to ask yourself
which piece is better and if your
opponent's piece is better just swap it
off and uh you know then then okay black
gets two uh also some double pawns but
his pawns are in a cluster and you want
your pawns in a cluster to defend each
other uh but yeah i think maybe left
could have taken that pawn in the middle
earlier but we have more exchanges here
david and um
what's happening now okay he's traded a
set of pawns in the center so black does
have an isolated pawn but
i guess it's not as weak as whites as
these counterparts over here um so black
still has the simple idea of dodging a
potential pin with his queen and then
targeting white's pawn
guess white now just has to activate his
rooks there's nothing else for it these
pieces are not doing anything right now
yeah look at that night though it's so
strong i mean
the problem is as soon as you take the
knight
black will get rid of his weakness that
bat you call it a backwards pawn it
can't be defended by another pawn um so
yeah if i if i was going to be this over
color here would be black at the moment
white trying to get his bishop in the
game there and black centralizing his
rooks um so still still fairly even
though
yep still plenty of life left and uh
abdu satoraf will be aiming to play
maybe even giving up some of these pawns
just for
the activity now but this last move
moving the white rook across one square
i'm slightly surprised i thought the
other rook would enter the game first
now black's queen can simply dodge this
uh this tension on the e file the key
file right now where all of the queens
and rooks are like
um so yeah i'm expecting the black queen
to sidestep
and still looks very healthy also the
evaluation bar
not liking this last white move it's
natural but
maybe
maybe just a bit too
casual this last move by white
and uh i do have to share with you
a poem that was written by dimitri
stanislav on twitter because it's about
double pawns
and it says double pawns make some no
noise push us forward scream they loud
we'll be fighting in the crowd wait a
moment thanks a man not right now i need
a plan time has come exchange and loud
pawns get out from the crowd
thank you very much
very nice poem and uh i just love it
when everyone contributes and tweets us
using the hashtag chess champs and we
will feature them on the screen yeah and
it was oh yeah keep the poem coming in
we have viabanka with her beautiful
english voice yeah that was mostly yes
well the poem was beautiful but that was
really well presented yeah
i agree you know if you ever need
another job i think theater
something
those books that you can have uh what do
you call it a mainland audiobook yeah i
would listen to books with the america's
voice yeah what about the mating game
have you ever thought about
making an audiobook from the mating game
bring it to life a little bit maybe
maybe yeah
you guys are making me blush
if you do the main female in the mating
game maybe i can be like the main male
you know i could be the cool one you
know like yeah
[Laughter]
i'm getting images in my head
all right back to the chest
[Laughter]
so the queen of this game not the queen
of the mating game has just moved for
black so level iranian just as expected
getting the black queen out of any
potential danger and abductor of look at
the clock times as well he's got half of
lebron ironian's time and he's got a
position where white has to be the more
accurate of the two the evaluation past
still undecided still roughly in the
middle but it's easier to play with
black because white has those weak pawns
and
i do worry for the young uzbek player
that if he can't find a plan over the
next two or three moves he will simply
get out maneuvered strategically it's
all about those pawns right now and uh
i'm expecting maybe white's queen to
move white bishop could jump in maybe to
attack the black rook the white light
squared bishop
options for white but options means you
have to consume more time on the clock
and level already just ruthless so far
just bang bang bang every move coming
instantly and okay a queen trade offered
i was going to say this this seems like
a very natural move david just moving
the queen there because
black would now not really not want to
swap the queens off because we've
mentioned time and time again how weak
white's pawns are and if the queens are
exchanged white gets rid of those double
pawns uh rectifies his pawns and his
bishops maybe come to life because you
kicked the knight away so uh i i'm
thinking how do you actually deal with
this mook because you're hitting
blackspawn on d6 he has exchanged wow
i'm amazed by that move yeah really i
think we all are look look how strong
these pawns are suddenly they were so
weak doubled a moment ago now they're
teaming up the only justification is
this knight jump yeah there's rook takes
bishop right as well yeah there's so
much to calculate i guess rook takes
bishop can be answered by a recapture
and you're relying on this pin your
anchor but then the knight can drop back
and take this pawn hitting the bishop
and defending the rook
i mean this position is still completely
fine for white i think after a trade
here or i can catch it in the center and
the game goes on but black would be
pretty safe so
i mean
it does feel so shaky for black those
types of ideas like rook takes bishop
sacrificing in order to activate these
bishops
um they are in the air for sure and
white's rook can just move maybe lifting
up maybe going this way ivanka you've
spotted another
like i spotted lots of moves it's like
there's so many attacking moves in the
position you know um abdusatorov has
actually attacked the knight but there
was also attacking the rook with one of
the bishops taking pawns
suddenly it's complicated and i think
it's going to favor only one person and
that's going to be abductor off yeah i
mean with the bishops you want to have
lots of open lines and uh previously the
black pawns were keeping the bishops
locked out of the position and white
from that previous sort of exchange has
opened up that dark square bishop the
light square bishop has opened up maybe
black is still okay but it seems to have
favored white this this last five moves
or so yeah white's only problem here i
mean now these bishops are fantastic but
the only problem is how to activate the
rooks and at the moment these two rooks
are a bit dominated by this black knight
this black knight is a bit of a thorn
in white side
especially this rook really wants to
enter the action but it can't right now
the square it wants to use is controlled
by black's knight so there are some
pluses to black's position i agree i
think there's no risk anymore for white
uh white will have ways to bail out
later
but okay first starting by trying to
activate this rook by opening up lines
pushing alice or arry or whatever that
porn is called pushing it forward
opening up lines for the rook behind it
and uh very logical move there by white
and again the evaluation bar still not
that concerned but it does feel like the
momentum has changed and suddenly
abductor is going to be so much happier
with this position than he was just five
moves ago
wow
all right what is the most likely result
in this game right now
it's hard to say all three results still
possible with best play it should most
likely be a draw but
but it's complicated yeah it's hard to
play perfect chess and rapid uh in the
rapid format oh yeah
yeah a big time difference as well
levona onion's played super fast in this
game so far he's still got 14 minutes
almost left on the clock
another beck is down to what is it six
minutes my eyesight is getting bad
that's right six minutes
and also i mean there will be twists and
turns ahead because level neronian we
talked about him losing that would
pretty much rule out his chances but
even with a draw he would have to win
his final game and his fate would no
longer be in his own hands he would have
to win his final game and hope that the
other results went in his favor so he
will be taking some risks as black in
this game to try and win and if you try
and take risks if uh if things go wrong
if you lose control then they could
backfire meanwhile black's rook's
teaming up
doubled pawns we've talked about a lot
but doubled rooks are a lot better and
those two black rooks now putting some
pressure on white's central pawn well
maybe there's a bit of a trach here
because i'd like to move my light square
bishop to attack that rook mean that be
the natural move to play where i you
know try to use my bishops on the open
board
but you know black black has a good
reply against this black uh can counter
attack by using that knight i think and
this this might well it does lead to an
advantage uh for black black will win a
pawn at least
um so uh yeah i mean maybe i was a
little bit hasty was saying oh wow
white's position is so great i mean lev
uh
went he did something very interesting
there which i think a lot of people
wouldn't do they they ruined their
structure but he's just basing
everything like a computer on
calculation maybe he's calculated that
these lines are are absolutely fine for
him and i think this is modern chess
nowadays
people relying on their calculation
abilities
and not just their instincts a lot more
than they used to because they analyze
with computers a lot more
well that's always a good move isn't it
h4 always no matter what they're
channeling their introdu uh inner ginger
gm
with this last move
actually as soon as you've arrived
they're just pushing this pawn in every
position
yeah
the harry effect yeah and we should
mention as well now it's less likely
that black will take this bishop over
the next few turns because if all the
rooks get traded off then white is left
at the very end with a protected past
pawn in the center of the board and this
pawn now means that if the bishops leave
white is simply winning this guy is
going to tie down at least the black
king or the black bishop so black
doesn't want to release the tension yet
and trade everything off so this is a
bit of a useful waiting move and black
meanwhile has nothing better to do than
centralize the king a good idea in
endgames however and abdushotorov avoids
any potential rook trades he's getting
ready to push both alice and harry most
likely and still very tense this endgame
and with a draw here uh tai has just
posted his uh qualification odds and
with a draw in this game they're both
going to be on 36 chance to qualify
but with a win here for another beck
he's going to be on 91 chance to qualify
and levon in that case will be down to
eight percent
it's uh it's one of those very crucial
games in terms of qualification
and another very crucial game in terms
of qualification is kaimer against liam
lee
and if if vincent kaimer the young
german wins that game he will be ready
for quarterfinals
so we're gonna pay attention to that one
as well
okay so he would be the first to qualify
other than the pontiac
maybe might be impressive
he's being so impressive i mean he's
another one of the younger players i
mean all the young players really have
have done fantastically well uh but
kaimo i don't he's not really as
mentioned as much maybe as like prague
or some other ones he's kind of
forgotten but
he's taught by the great peter lecko um
who's his pupil you know and everyone
knows how fantastic peter lecko is and
uh
he's uh yeah he's he's he's a real real
talent and he's proved that in this
competition so it'd be good to see him
qualify yeah i mean this this whole
event feels like a coming-of-age
tournament for all these guys i mean
we've talked about them for years prague
has been on the radar after years
abductor off as well uh kymer but now
they're all putting it together they're
all really
giving nightmares to the top players in
the world the new established elite like
iranian like carson wow what a clever
move that is is that a clever move black
now can go and grab a pawn
uh white just leaving a pawn on pries
and just bring the king in instead let's
see what happens if black gets greedy
after this king move if black takes this
pawn we would see a rook trade and i
think this is genius by abducted off
because look at this rook it lacks
escape squares it's only got two squares
to go to at the moment back to the
center or to capture this pawn and white
can solve both of those issues at once
white can give a check to the black king
and when the king moves now a pawn push
or even a king move would trap this
black rook it has to give itself up for
a bishop and that is not enough so levon
aronian he doesn't make that mistake he
doesn't make that blunder and fall into
the trap that abduces the torah set for
him instead he brings his bishop to the
side forcing a rook trade and one set of
rooks are off the board also double
attack this guy under fire and this kind
of fire
uh we do therefore see uh abductor toro
try to release his rook he's trying to
get it open and uh if it does somehow
sneak up to the seventh rank it will
have targets
i have a feeling that satoru might have
been too clever for his own good
thinking yeah it's definitely
overthinking you know because it was a
nice fancy trap but i'm looking at this
position and i'm thinking ah that phone
can now drop off and also if black is
really sorry if white is really careless
then black will have a past pawn there
on the left and that can be difficult to
handle yeah this will be a past pawn and
it might be a weakness but it also could
be very strong if it starts marching
down the board and note how this rook
will no longer be trapped because it has
extra escape squares on this left side
now so this bishop moved by level
iranian may be turning things in his
favor
and also the clock times still vastly in
his favor there in this in the position
you had there david uh was white's idea
just played rook b1
and aim for a draw i think this is maybe
uh
potentially what what white's going for
now white realizing that black's so
active for the centralized work uh
in rook endings maybe the most important
thing is having the active rook even if
you have to give up a pawn and white's
just trying to swap some some bits off
now and try to secure a draw possibly
that's this idea of this move i think
you're completely right and abusive
torah if you saw him kind of exhale like
oh just sighing he knows that his
winning chances in this game are mostly
disappeared now live on a running if he
wants at least a draw he can just take
that pawn and i think all the danger is
gone for black
white is the one fighting for his life i
think he should achieve the draw
we might well see exactly what we just
showed on the board okay the black rook
did go and grab a pawn black's one pawn
up right now we saw a trade and okay i'm
surprised we didn't see almost simon
just shuffling the white rock across one
square hitting the black bishop and the
pawn behind it instead a check from
white's room this is a much riskier way
to play i mean i i think white realized
that he could have taken the draw there
so it shows that white is trying to win
this position um which is good news for
iranian because aronia wants his
opponent to overpress as well uh given
himself winning chances i mean uh
i i'm assuming like the black king can
now come forwards and it could be
another race maybe if white grabs the
king's side pawn i think you're right uh
black's king now okay
backwards i thought it was gonna go
forward yeah very greedy in end games i
think 99 of the time if you can go
forward you want to go forward activate
your king here black's king now is cut
off on the back rank and won't be an
active piece also it just allows more
checks so abdu satorov
will just keep checking that king he
shook his head there slightly surprising
uh maybe level norman just wants to
repeat the position once show he's in
charge and then go active with the black
king but we'll learn a lot now we'll
live on iranian take the risk go active
with his king but allow some pawns to
fall
he needs to win this game
if he doesn't then he's really going to
be up against it in the last round of
the day
yeah i mean what is the risk involved
you know because once the king steps
forward
presumably the white rook won't capture
the pawn immediately maybe there will be
some little intermediate move
just to
chase away the rook and over protect
those pawns on the right okay so let's
keep an eye on the players as well
because we might see some reactions
black's king now is checked if it
retreats we'll see white continue to
chase this king and the position will
just repeat itself if levon ironian in
the current position wants to win the
game he has to go forward with his king
but as mentioned uh by johannko and
simon there this does come with risk
because this pawn might drop um yovanka
mentioned maybe flicking in an
intermediate move going for this pawn i
guess um this is weak but black can
defend it maybe with his own rook
uh but yeah risk will be involved
because this pawn will fall and maybe
after rook takes pawn
there might be some problems still for
example this rook now has to commit does
it defend this pawn or does it go and
defend this pawn later i'm not sure you
can hold them both
okay level goes the other way with this
king wow really surprising yeah yeah i
mean normally you want to centralize
your king and put it in front of your
opponent's past pawn uh so this is this
is a little bit surprising but i even if
lev loses this game i like what he's
doing also i don't want to bring back
painful memories for you david but i'm
going to um
thank you sorry dave it's so kind that's
what i'm here for but i remember when
you had a chance to qualify for the
candidates and then your opponent
played well basically for a draw
and you realize that okay um if it's
going to be a draw i'm not going to
qualify so i have to play some
outrageous risk which you did and okay
you lost a very painful game but i think
you made the right decision you know
sometimes you just have to go for it and
this is i feel what lev's doing here
he's making the right practical decision
yeah he's a pawn up after all if you
count the pawns this black pawn
potentially might win the game
especially if the rooks disappear
it has no rival it is a past pawn you
just have to keep an eye on this white
pawn from marching down the board at the
moment it's fine because black's bishop
covers the advance but that could all
change so that is the risk involved for
ironian also the black king a bit
offside and you can definitely imagine
it getting checked at some point and
having to
move even further away from the center
so level ironian trying something here
still a draw is likely but at least
keeping the game alive and that's what
we like to see tenth round and look at
the kostenik against eric hansen cause
daniel she's lost all her game so far
the only female player in the tournament
but she
could be about to win her first game
gaining three points
and that's not good news for eric hansen
of course who is fighting to qualify but
it is looking good for him even if he
loses that game but uh that would be
nice of course to get some points also
for alexander kostanyuk
yeah i actually mentioned this to ivanka
yesterday this is just always how it
happens i hope she gets a result at some
point but um normally the player who's
struggling in the tournament always gets
a result against the player who's in
form because the in-form player maybe
just relaxes a bit too much puts too
much pressure on beating the tail ender
to play on the bottom of the rankings
and that's when that kind of underdog
gets the chances so
i mean that would be
bad times for eric but kustenik uh yeah
it will be great for her i think the
whole world is on christina's side right
now definitely uh so okay meanwhile a
couple of moves black's king forced to
go right to the edge of the board
white's king going towards the black
rook now actually a big threat in the
position white's king if it steps one
square across hits the black rook hits
the black bishop as well and that would
cause some real issues for iranian
so i'm expecting him to move his bishop
but where to
well he's just playing with fire
actually it's quite quite tactical now
isn't it i mean uh this idea of king c3
i'm not even sure it does win a piece
but it's very close to winning a piece
um but lev's got what he wants i think
here uh from from at least complicating
the the position yeah yeah one thing
that he has to do with a bishop though
is he has to stay along that diagonal oh
yeah i think simon's right this one is
hanging by a thread but it does
i think not lose a piece for black if
white's king marches across now the
black rook will step back and
it's yeah it's just about fine there's
going to be counter attacks there's
going to be tricks
there's going to be meeting threats with
counter threats i mean i just don't like
the black king i mean max king is so
poorly placed
you have to watch king can step forward
as well right
you have to watch out for g4 g5 you know
check mates in in certain certain cases
i mean there's maybe some combination of
white central porn coming through
distracting black and uh then creating
some chances against black's king but
black black is a porno so you know
you're right sir if you get two moves if
you're allowed to play two moves in a
row this would be checkmate yes
maybe you could if you're playing over
the board you could you could try
playing it in one move so what your
opponent does but you can't do that when
you're playing online because it won't
let you it's a little bit naughty i know
but i've seen worse
chess tricking europe
what's the dirtiest trick you've ever
seen in a blitz game uh is quite an
interesting question i mean i i remember
breakfast very quickly that there were
two grand masters playing next to me
one of them was completely winning he
had like uh he was like a queen and
something up but he only had six seconds
left yeah and uh you know he's about to
check mate his opponent on the other
hand um pointed at his clock and said
you're tired look at your time you've
run out of time but you actually had two
seconds left and by the time he realized
he was like
his time had run out and uh completely
cheating yeah so
isn't that cheating
he was lying he said your time's run out
but the guy just looked at it and i i
was watching he went 2-1 and he was like
it hadn't run out so yeah i'm incredibly
dirty that was the touches i've seen
it's really weird you mentioned that
simon that's happened to me twice two of
my opponents have done that against me
both times i lost on time one was even
in a classical game that's illegal i
mean you should name it can we name and
shame
like a famous uh grandmaster and
commentator now like
you can tell me later i'll tell you
later
the famous commentator as well what's
happening blitz i had three seconds and
a completely winning position of rook up
and he said this he said time and i
looked over and then he held my end of
the world i held the end of the clock oh
my god i complained to the arbiter but
there was no view there were no
spectators in an official game as well
yeah he held your clock down so you can
that's so dirty and i was yeah so you
can't press it and just like exactly
exactly wow wow
that is really nasty trick i'm very
interested to hear who this is
i'm really interested
it happened in a classical game where my
opponent was just like whoa and he just
stood up and then i looked at the clock
he was pointing at it and it had three
or four seconds and i was just so in
shock i just i just froze oh gosh
that must have made you rather angry
my
meanwhile a couple of moves so
black's bishop did run away to safety um
i was going to show actually early on
the board but just to explain white's
bishop could have attacked the black
rook a few moves ago the black rook tied
down to its bishop but there would have
been counter attacks against the white
rook so no way to win material for
abductor of instead white rook has kind
of gone on an adventure protecting
white's central past pawn and meanwhile
black is now giving a check forcing the
white king to commit do you step forward
maybe walking into more checks if you
step forward with the white king which
way do you go do you go towards the
black pawn or do you go towards the
center to support your own porn this is
really cunning kind of speed chess
tactics from aronian forcing white to
make big decisions with not that much
time on the clock um this is one thing
you should always do as long as it
doesn't worsen your position give your
opponent choice and here abu satoru only
has really two logical moves maybe but
uh there are pros and cons to both of
them so he will spend even more time
trying to work it out you can see
abdusatorov
confused maybe about what he should be
aiming for here with white
some interesting situations going on
when we look at the bottom of the screen
all the bars magnus carlsen could be
about to win against chocolate mountain
that's going to mean the magnus is
qualified for the knockout stage
duda he is uh out of the tournament but
it's looking good for him against
yesopenko and that is bad news for
esapenko who is fighting to qualify uh
as mentioned costeno could be about to
win against eric hanson um what else
liam led the bar slightly over to his
side in that very crucial game against
vincent kymer some interesting games
going on but this one is maybe the most
interesting this one is still very tense
despite the uh lack of material on the
board and now level nerolian can he just
get greedy and grab a second pawn
yeah i think he's going to jumps up yeah
he wants to win this game greed can be
good
yeah as gordon gekko famously said great
film
but yeah taking taking that pawn on h4 i
mean you you should always look at the
most critical move first right i mean if
you can take the pawn take the pawn
does i mean the only danger is white
white's e porn is incredibly strong but
the black king can maybe just come back
i guess you come back and uh and of
course the bishop that is sitting there
all the way in the corner he's doing a
great job eyeing up the pawn so together
teamwork makes the dream work and i
think that pawn can be easily handled i
think no risk at all behind that
decision so we're expecting blacks rook
just to swing across and capture harry
white's h4 pawn and
as the reason i mentioned no risk is
because even if white central pawn does
match up the board even if you
miscalculate something there you will be
able to give up black's bishop for that
white central pawn and black has plenty
of pawns you will never ever lose that
end game even if you give up your bishop
for one of white's pawns so so is this
going to be a maybe maybe a case of
fortune favors the brave uh lev has been
extremely brave playing on it he
probably had to but uh
again one of the biggest improvements i
made in chess was when i just stopped
having draws you know you're going to
lose a lot of games but eventually it's
going to teach you um how to pray play
you know to fight and uh you've got to
fight in chess and this is what ronia is
showing here yeah you've got to push
your own boundaries right you got to
kind of understand how much risk is too
much uh is too much you got to
i mean i realized i made a big jump as
well when i just stopped accepting draws
when i was younger just because you
learn something you lose or you yeah you
win or you learn so um okay black's rook
now coming back after grabbing a pawn
he's gonna go maybe up the board and try
and stop what it's pawn from the side uh
really uh interesting stuff there by
levon ironian now the black rook under
fire from a white bishop and wow he just
pushes his pawn forward his pride and
joy the past pawn but if white goes in
place bishop takes pawn right now
capturing that black pawn that has just
moved to blackrock has access to a
central square it will swing back to the
middle checking the white king and
picking up
white's central pawn nice move nice move
and my instinct first was actually just
to retreat the rook to the seventh row
and just keep an eye on that past pawn
but uh this is such a nice trick but
okay
nor debeck just consolidates his pawn
you know the bishop is on the perfect
offensive and defensive square
controlling the promotion square yeah
also black's work i mean when you're
playing against past pawns you should
always try to get your rook behind your
opponent's passport and lev has now done
that he's got his work behind the pass
pawn the ideal square to to stop your
opponent from queening and he's and he's
got barry our friend barry the b pawn um
people are going to get so they already
are you're so sick of the name of the
pause oh we love it yeah only if you've
heard it for the first time
it's certainly not the first time i
called it all barry but i i think here
this is this this using the b pawn to
distract us it's almost game over it's
going to be too strong i know one player
who is sick of the sight of all these
pawns is abducted
because he's just running out of pawns
black is four for two up in terms of
pawns and look at this look at
abdulsatora's face right now
he knows he's blown this one black's
bishop now lining up against the white
king white's king's gonna have to lose
even more time and ivanka i must admit i
hate the position of white's bishop he's
just not contributing at all badly
placed i agree white bishop and white's
rook are both tied down defending its
pawn and black has a runner that b pawn
is gonna run down the board
it's gonna cost white some material and
then the black king can rejoin the
action black has so many pawns in
reserve for later there we go the pawn
marching and this black pawn is actually
even more dangerous than white's pawn
which
is currently under lock and key
yep and remember with a win here levon
will be at 79 chance to uh qualify
and of the satori will be down to 17
chance with a loss here
that's going to be painful as well
because for so long
he was uh well he had a level position
if anything he was the one taking risks
earlier to try and win but then as soon
as levon already maintained that tension
he lost control obviously toro and that
can happen in end games and uh yeah
levon just keeps it simple the the uh
it's a tony miles approach
swapping pieces off and now getting rid
of the bishops yes a pawn has
disappeared for black but white's pawn
has disappeared and three versus one in
a rook in game it's too much one pawn
advantage maybe you can save it but when
your opponent has two extra pawns it's
normally hopeless and black's paws are
connected as well this is just a matter
of time now
wow
yeah not much to say black's just gonna
move the rook out the way it slowly used
the black king to shepherd the black
pawns forward and
it's to be game over this one is
hopeless oh no
look at the pain for abductor of
obviously aware of the tournament
situation